hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I think it's time for another Tips &
Tricks video for those who can't deny
their addiction to the hot knife Battle
Royale whether you are a dirty casual
like me or a pro in waiting putting in
30 hours a week these 25 tips should
keep you one step ahead of your rivals
before we start we are nine seasons deep
into fortnight Battle Royale if you
could only rock one skin for the rest of
your days who would you choose which one
would it be about your favorites in the
comments below for me it's a tough
choice but I have to say in May so sorry
we're sick of Sheen and I said ah I've
no idea what I said but it was Japanese
it sounded awesome anyway let's get off
with this tips and twitch pros let's do
this let's start with getting out of the
battle bus and to the ground first did
you know that aiming straight into the
air thrusters can cancel your glide
animation you have to be completely
above it when you drop from the bus but
then straight down into the airflow
without your glider pop in pretty damn
cool it's a game changer
sticking with those bladeless fans have
you ever been shot whilst rotating to
other areas we found that consistently
leaving the jet stream and re-entering
it makes you a harder target to hit and
surprisingly it's only slightly slower
than staying inside the current at all
times here's a speed comparison
if you use this method you'll also be
able to surprise enemies by landing on
top of those funds I know it's early
days but you'll be surprised how long
people take to notice and when they do
jump straight back into the slipstream
and take up yet another attack point
just in case you weren't aware of it you
can enter those slip streams with a
vehicle and you'll receive a free
redeploy so pass through one with a quad
crusher for extra safety you never know
you may be shot out of midair and fall
to your death prevent that by going
through the slipstream as a side note
The Geysers offer fall invulnerability
to when entering with the vehicle so
free invulnerability and a free glider
I'm not gonna turn that down in a
previous video we talked about the
brilliance of the block a constantly
changing area that if you learn the
layout quick enough you can dominate
there constantly we already know about
the super secret top tier chest hidden
at the block but there's a few other
reasons why it's such a great place to
start especially when it's away from the
battle bus path you know when there's
less people around depending on the
design of the block the materials on
offer are astounding and the main reason
why it's because everything there is
destructible and therefore mine worthy
keep in mind some elements and not worth
any resources at all but the majority of
the time it's excellent and to build on
this point the block has proven to have
the most ammo spawn points on the entire
map at the end of season eight one block
had 21 ammo spawns a our ammo for days
[Music]
let's turn our attention to the respawn
box where we reboot our friends they've
changed how we play the game here's a
few things though to remember around
them firstly remember they are
indestructible use them for natural
cover you can also be relatively safe as
building near the fans is impossible but
here's how I personally use them
tactically have you ever been in a
position where you've knocked and killed
one enemy but alas their partner cannot
be found this may be a little passive
but simply wait by the reboot ban they
will come to you and more often than not
they'll be focused on raising their
teammates and hand you yet another easy
kill and even better than that they
bring all their loot to your feet so if
you lose an enemy keep an eye on the
nearest respawn point the sight of huge
builds around the reboot fund can give
extra attention in battle so here's
something to keep in mind using a cone
or pyramid to hide underneath during the
respawn wait an extra layer of safety
without using all your mats and gaining
unwanted attention
respawn within a cone this one isn't
really a tip it's just the right thing
to do when you pick up a friend's banner
try to take a weapon for them to the
pistol they automatically receive isn't
great this is also your opportunity to
drop minis to split maps and ammo
getting your teammate back is only the
first step get them back into the fight
instead of hunting for loot this can all
tie into the shadow bond - it's possible
to collect teammates banners whilst in
the Shadow Realm grabbing them during
fights is completely possible run in run
out get the team back together before
going back into war so even if you're
the last man standing in the squad and
you really don't have a chance one
shadow bomb can be your ticket into
winning the shadow bomb is also great to
have at the last few circles as it
negates fall damage from height I've
also tried to use it to see if it's
possible to remain unnoticed in the last
few circles it is but it's damn scary
feeling helpless as a general point
though using a shadow bomb to save maps
in later game can be a lifesaver
as we're on the shadow bomb did you know
that you can scale entire mountains with
it the shadow bomb can be used
unlimitedly on the
Sections the timer doesn't run out if
you're in peril like vertically climbing
a mountain so hypothetically you could
simply jump on the side of a mountain
indefinitely so the time has come to
look at getting into those annoying
turtle houses I'm going to start with
the most obvious tip on earth and I'm
only just starting to use it two years
after game launched while replacing in
duo's back in the old days when two of
us were attacking a turtling opponent we
take aside each and spam through the
wall well since turbo building and
sensitivities have changed and improved
and quickened this isn't as easy as it
used to be but there's something far
more simple the first player can simply
pickaxe the wall as the second person
stands ready to turbo build a brand new
one depending on your ping you have a
50/50 chance of getting it no need to
waste bullets now simply edit and take
the e limb in a very efficient way I did
say it was obvious but come on be honest
did you ever try it before I know I
didn't the wall removed tactic we are
used to use has now been patched but
there are a few ways to replicate it by
setting up a cone and editing a corner
you can be at a safe angle from the
enemy inside is one by one from here
pickaxe multiple areas at once roof tile
wall wall hopefully they'll be so
confused about which structure you're
breaking that you'll get an easy replace
we still can break another person's wall
from behind a ramp but it's a little
harder in season 9 as long as we hit the
top of their wall before ramping up the
crit stays in the same place allowing
you to remove and replace the wall from
the safety of your own ramp do you ever
go up against those window Pickers in
scenarios like this have you tried
throwing in a trap when they open the
window
all that takes too much skill for me if
I have Dynamite's on nades
I simply put them on the top and go back
to the tried and tested routine of
shooting them through the roof it's an
oldie but it's a bloody good one as
always I'd like to take a few seconds
after this video to thank those people
who've used code a damaru in the support
a creator shop you guys make these
videos possible and like bloody love you
for it
anyway if you'd like your name to be
here with all these leggings simply send
me a video on Twitter of you buying
something with my code I appreciate it
massively anyway stop it with the
self-promotion Adam back to the video so
the flintlock pistol is a great tool to
use to traverse or save yourself from
high falls well did you know that when
crouching the Flint nock does not force
you backwards in our test stick didn't
always work maybe that's by design or
it'll take victims soon we'll see so
when you use it up high and don't want
to risk falling either place a wall
behind you or simply bend the knee
whilst playing around with the Flint
nock we discovered this it's possible to
knock someone out of their glider in
mid-air so if you're being pushed shoot
them and watch them regret their actions
okay so here's a really cool one when
being shot from a cannon you can reload
all your weapons every single one of
them so be prepared for a fight who are
rotating and yes in this case I
literally mean rotating as lobbies
become sweaty or and sweaty oh we all
need to think about preserving mats I'm
sure you've seen those turtle rat runs
in the endgame well if you're by the
side of the storm use a rotated ramp to
quickly get to the next circle they
offer cover from the side and above
which is pretty useful once safely into
the next circle remember to rotate it
back I always forget and die unduly oh
here's a good one to finish on now we
can't see our teammate skills it can be
difficult to know if you're being
carried or you're a worthy member of the
team but we can check on ps4 press
options followed by the touch cut and
voila there's their kills just there I'm
not sure what these buttons are on PC
switch and Xbox but it's the options
button followed by the map key hopefully
that will help you figure it out
okay so there we have it a few tips and
tricks to keep you ahead of the game in
fortnight / season 9 and beyond thanks
for watching I'm Adam come talk to me
over on Twitter
I'm Adam grenade over there also a huge
thank you to Zack Gigi he's the master
behind most of these tips so I'll link
his channel below if you want to go give
him some love if you sub to him now
you'll be within the first 1000 people
one day he will have millions it's been
an absolute pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]
yes use go down tomorrow in the pharma
job thanks again I'll see you next time